Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm breaking down the amazing new
Avengers: Infinity War trailer for Marvel
easter eggs and other cool details you might
have missed.
If you're here for the first time, I do regular
Marvel videos, and to celebrate the new trailer,
I'm kicking off a new round of my Infinity
War giveaway for all my subscribers.
Just leave me a comment below about the new
trailer or any requests you have for Infinity
War videos.
Obviously, speculation and potential spoilers
ahead for Infinity War.
The new trailer introduces more backstory
for Thanos with Gamora revealing her father's
chilling mission.
"The entire time I knew him, he only ever
had one goal."
"To wipe out half the universe."
"If he gets all the infinity stones, he can
do it with the snap of his fingers...
just like that!"
And that snap is a reference to the classic
Infinity Gauntlet storyline where Thanos literally
snaps his fingers when he's wearing the gauntlet
and half of the universe disappears.
This is an awesome easter egg although we
might not actually get Thanos's exact "snap"
moment in the movie.
For example, we may see the Mad Titan's fingers
about to perform that move, followed by a
sudden cut to black, similar to how at the
end of Avengers: Age of Ultron the camera
cut before Cap finished the famous comic book
catchphrase, 'Avengers Assemble!'
"Avengers..."
Thanos's voiceover is as chilling as his mission
and proves that his view of balancing the
universe is a twistedly positive one.
"The end is near."
"When I'm done, half of humanity will still
exist."
"Perfectly balanced ... as all things should
be"
Notice how Thanos is a glass-half-full guy.
He's pointing out half of humanity will still
exist in perfect balance.
Of course, Thanos will need the time stone,
and we get a terrifying shot of Ebony Maw
torturing Doctor Strange.
And it instantly brought to mind this scene
from the comics where Ebony Maw manipulates
Doctor Strange into becoming an unwitting
pawn for Thanos.
Ebony Maw has the ability to deceive even
the strongest of minds and I think we're going
to see Doctor Strange used by Maw in some
kind of deception against the Avengers.
Thor gets some pretty incredible scenes in
the new trailer.
We see him with Rocket and Groot on the Dwarven
planet Nidavellir, where he's gone in search
of a new weapon now that he no longer has
his hammer Mjolnir.
And we get to see an awesome scene where a
cape-wearing-Thor powers up and harnesses
either his own lightning powers or the powers
of something else, perhaps an Infinity Stone,
to create his new weapon.
It's not shown in the trailer, but various
tie-in toys have confirmed that the new weapon
will be Stormbreaker and the handle looks
to be made from wood that Groot donates from
his own body.
Stormbreaker is an axe-like hammer which in
the comics was originally wielded by Beta
Ray Bill.
Bill is a popular comic-book character who,
after proving himself worthy enough to wield
Thor's normally unliftable hammer, was given
the new hammer, Stormbreaker, by Odin.
And like Mjolnir, Bill's hammer was created
by the dwarves of Nidavellir.
In the comics, Stormbreaker had the same powers
as Thor's Mjolnir, so it'll be interesting
to see how Thor uses it in Infinity War and
if there are any differences with his original
hammer.
In the previous trailer we saw the Black Order
attempt to extract the Mind Stone from Vision's
forehead, and as I predicted then, the Avengers
have taken Vision to Wakanda to try and safely
remove it.
In this shot, Wakandan high-tech genius Shuri
is using her kimoyo beads to project an image
of Vision, who you can see lying down at the
bottom of the screen.
She looks to be showing this image to Bruce
Banner, whose glasses you can see flash by
just to the side of the shot.
Shuri seems to be working out or actually
even showing Banner how she can extract the
Mind Stone from Vision while keeping him alive.
We know from the Avengers: Infinity War prelude
comic and the Black Panther post-credits scene
that Shuri has developed tech in Wakanda that
removed the HYDRA programming from Bucky's
brain, so it's not surprising that the Avengers
would call on her again for her brilliance
at inventing and using cutting-edge tech,
this time to try to help Vision.
As was hinted at in the first trailer, Bruce
Banner will be getting into Tony's Hulkbuster
armour.
And I really liked this shot of the Hulkbuster
standing tall and Falcon and War Machine flying
past behind him.
But later it looks like the Hulkbuster might
not be strong enough to withstand the Outrider
attack as we see him getting overwhelmed.
If you're worried about Bruce Banner's chances
of survival, well, I think he's probably going
to get out of this one because a recent toy
shows Bruce Banner hulking out while inside
the Hulkbuster.
Also the first trailer showed a Hulk without
any armour fighting on the Wakandan battlefield.
Hopefully then an angry Hulk will be able
to take out the Outriders swarming all over
him at this point!
This flashback shows Thanos and his army conquering
Gamora's people, with the Mad Titan taking
a young Gamora away from her family to raise
as his own.
Remember that in the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies, we've seen how Gamora is very much
Thanos's favourite, which really hurt Nebula
when they were growing up together.
In a recent interview with EW, Josh Brolin
said that although Thanos uses his adoptive
daughter Gamora as a tool for his own gain,
he does feel affection for her and we'll see
the evolution of their relationship over the
course of the film in flashback scenes like
this one.
After all, conquering other places and races,
and taking away some of their youngsters,
was all part of Thanos's grand plan, which
we'll see snap into place in Infinity War.
The fact that Gamora is Thanos's favourite
may well mean that, in his eyes, her betrayal
of all he stands for is simply unbearable.
This is one of many reasons I believe the
Mad Titan will sacrifice Gamora by the end
of Infinity War.
And I talk about all the clues pointing to
her demise in my new Infinity War Death Theory
video.
OK, let's talk Iron Man.
We get to see a bit more of his suit capabilities
when his foot thrusters convert into a supercharged
rocket booster as he zooms up to the circle
of death which we know from previous promos
has Spider-Man on board.
The machine heads out into space and we later
see it smash onto a reddish-orangy-brown coloured
planet and in the background there's a ton
of wreckage.
This planet or moon is Thanos's homeworld
Titan.
As well as the flashback scenes with Gamora,
we're likely going to see flashbacks to Thanos's
earlier life on Titan.
Recently, Kevin Feige explained we'll learn
that Titan's population went extinct "because
of things that [Thanos] thought he could help
prevent, [but] he was not allowed to do [anything
about them]."
And after that mass extinction, Thanos "vowed
not to let [it] happen again."
Now, in the background of the planet there
are various giant objects strewn around which
are likely left over from Titan's destruction.
In fact, I wonder whether they might be parts
of a giant machine.
Remember in Guardians of the Galaxy, the Collector
introduced us to the power of the Infinity
Stones and we saw a Celestial destroying a
whole planet.
It might be that something similar happened
on Titan and Celestials attacked Thanos's
homeworld.
Recently, the Russo Brothers said we should
prepare for a lot of crying in the cinema
when we watch Avengers: Infinity War and Kevin
Feige has also said we will be getting real
character deaths.
And in this new trailer, I think we get the
biggest hint that Iron Man might actually
die.
Listen to Thanos and watch who it cuts back
to.
Tony's looking pretty beaten down by this
point with his armour broken, and Thanos's
words obviously echo the fact that Iron Man
kick-started the whole of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
I also think it's interesting that the Marvel
Studios intro logo was zoomed right in on
the R when it came on in this trailer and
right there bang in the centre are 2 pictures
of Tony Stark, a subtle hint perhaps that
he's at the core of this movie?
We've also had all the Soul Stone promo art
teases with Iron Man in the middle of the
Soul Stone, and I'm getting a feeling Marvel
could want Infinity War to come full circle
back to the very first movie in the franchise,
Iron Man.
Robert Downey Jr has said that he wants to
leave on a high, and going out in a blaze
of glory in Infinity War would definitely
fit that ambition.
If Tony Stark really does die, I'm sure there
will be a ton of misty eyes in the theatre.
Now, the editing in the trailer could, of
course, be a bit of classic misdirection.
Thanos might be saying this line to someone
else, for example, Spider-Man who we saw getting
beaten down by Thanos in the first trailer,
or perhaps to Thor or Cap who we also see
Thanos attack in the new trailer.
By the way, even if Iron Man does die, we're
going to see Tony Stark again in Avengers
4 as RDJ's been filming, so we'll either get
flashback scenes or some time-travel shenanigans
that the remaining Avengers do to try to fix
the events of Infinity War.
So, if Iron Man potentially dying wasn't enough
for you, the trailer actually immediately
cut to Steve Rogers resisting Thanos and the
gauntlet.
First of all, it's incredible that Cap appears
to be holding Thanos back with just his hands.
And that reminds me of how Cap was the only
one who managed to make Mjolnir wobble a little
in Thor's hammer lifting contest in Age of
Ultron, and also of how Cap held on to The
Winter Soldier's helicopter in Civil War.
As for Cap's chances against the Mad Titan,
well, he does have his new shields which are
bound to have some new capabilities we've
not yet seen.
However, notice in this shot that Cap's right
arm is missing its shield, but in this later
shot, the shield is back!
This could mean simply that these two shots
in the trailer are shown in a different order
than they appear in the final movie, or it
might mean that Cap's arm shields are similar
to his triangular shield in the comics, in
other words, part of his shield is used to
protect himself while the other part splits
off to attack a baddie.
And I talk in detail about Cap's new shield
in my video on that.
I am still worried for Cap though because
in the Infinity Gauntlet story when Steve
Rogers went up against Thanos, the Mad Titan
easily crushed Captain America's shield and
then killed him like he was nothing.
I'm hoping Cap might hold out better here
but I wouldn't place a bet on his chances
of survival.
OK, on a more upbeat note, I want to appreciate
how awesome this shot of Spidey swinging through
the floating wreckage of Titan is.
It looks like this scene is from the aftermath
of when Thanos throws a moon at the planet
which was recently released in a still and
I imagine the Avengers might have survived
this attack perhaps because Doctor Strange
managed to slow down time for himself and
the other heroes as the moon landed on the
surface.
Now, I'd love to hear your thoughts and theories
on the new trailer.
What's got you excited?
And who's got you worried?
Also, leave me any requests or questions you
have about the trailer which I'll follow up/answer
in another video.
You can leave those in the comments or tweet
me @Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that like button and sharing the video.
The winner of my last Marvel giveaway is on
screen now.
If that's you, send me a private message with
your details and I'll get your prize out to
you.
And if you want to check out my Infinity War
Death Theory video or my other Marvel theory
and trailer breakdowns, tap the screen right
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!